the other welds plays just like a
full-out game that's a pretty tepid
description and an obvious comparison
it's easy to take one look at the game
which strongly echos the mechanical form
of Bethesda RPGs and think you know what
to expect but the Auto Wells doesn't
just play like a full-out game it is
surprisingly the best possible version
of a Fallout game a potent distillation
of what made that series so beloved in
the first place just to keep from
damaging the board's bottom line
[Music]
the atom world's adopts the most
compelling innovations of modern Fallout
games emphasizing immersive exploration
and impactful action-oriented combat in
a game engine that actually makes those
things feel good by contemporary
standards it shares fallout satirical
but incredibly bleak look at the future
but it's free of its tide tropes
critically the outer worlds exhibits the
same depth of soul as the early
interplay in Black Isle Fallout games
with a genuinely complex interconnected
narrative web of relationships and
events that feel like they can change in
a seemingly infinite number of ways
based on the character you want to be
the variety of choices you can make and
the actions you can take but that's not
the only element that makes the outer
walls an excellent space Western
adventure it's just the incredibly sound
foundation that elevates the game's
great world building wonderful
characters and multi-layered quest
design on top of punchy combat and
consistently sharp writing in the other
worlds you are just one of thousands of
people left in hibernation on an
abandoned colony ship when a scientist
have possibly ill repute freeze you and
enlists your help in saving the rest of
your frozen peers after a rigorous
character creation process involving a
slew of variable attributes perks and
aesthetic customization you crash land
on a planet alone and from there how you
make your mark on the healthy and system
is up to you the crux of the sci-fi
setup is that among other things the
halcyon system is owned and run entirely
by a board of corporations and their
presence is a big deal
corporate capitalism so deeply affects
everything in the outer worlds and
explorations into how it can affect
society on a variety of levels it's a
surprisingly well considered constant
despite the semblance of parody you'll
meet sympathetic workers whose
livelihood
made possible by offering themselves to
exploitation in indentured servitude
white collared outlaws who are more
bureaucrats than pirates and
well-meaning middle managers who are
just trying to change the corporate
machine from the inside you'll find
moderates idealists extremists and most
things in between and around the fringes
all of whom have their own feasible
ideas about how to best serve the colony
or themselves by the time the climax
hits it's clear that the outer world has
its own stance on this bleak future but
that doesn't stop the world that creates
the surgeons you take and characters you
meet along the way from being any less
fascinating now there are plenty of
characters in the outer worlds who I
didn't like Reed Thompson for example is
a sniveling factory chief in the early
hours of the game who I didn't have to
think twice about undermining and Felix
one of your potential companion
characters had such an annoyingly naive
personality I avoided talking to him as
much as possible now the outer world
allows you to kill any character in the
game bar one and the world will reshape
and move on without them but there's
something to be said for the game's
depiction of its unappealing people
whose portrayal I admire despite my
distaste I never felt like I'd to enjoy
stretches of pointless or overly
dramatic exchanges both because of how
focused and subtle the script seemed to
be as well as the variety of response
options for my play character which kept
conversations flowing in largely natural
ways numerous considerations of the
world state like conversations take into
account things you may or may not have
already done throughout your campaign
and solid consistent voice direction
helps keep the tone firmly measured
meaning the hours you spend absorbing
the world through its people are always
engaging but nowhere does the strength
of the game's characters shine more
strongly than in your companions however
report Bo gets drunk surprised
human you are in violation of
cleanliness ordinance eight eight eight
six you have the option to recruit six
predetermined characters to accompany
and assist you in your adventures who
instantly feel like fleshed out
characters of their own accord not
simply like they exist to revolve around
you
they'll converse privately with each
other and chime in on conversations you
have with other characters in the world
acting is sounding boards during key
moments life is fated and unstoppable
companions are their own customizable
skill trees equipment loadouts combat
tactics and special abilities you can
command them to use which with their
cinematic camera angles inspired battle
cries and useful status effects never
become unsatisfying to initiate the
other major tool at your disposal in
combat provided your character's weapon
skills are high enough to use it is the
tactical time-dilation a time vending
mechanic that slows the action to a
crawl allowing you to give yourself some
breathing room in order to analyze
enemies and take time to execute
precision attacks now despite having
strong RPG foundations the combat in the
outer world is very much focused on
first-person action incorporating things
like parries blocks and dodges on top of
an array of melee weapons and Firearms
there's a hectic and fast-paced fluidity
to comment that feels very good however
that's aided by some enthusiastic sound
design which does most of the heavy
lifting and giving all weapons some
satisfying feedback a range of science
weapons bring some creative diversity
into your arsenal and features guns that
have unique entertaining properties like
shrinking enemies or turning them
against each other the only problem with
combat is that on the game's recommended
regular difficulty it eventually turns
into a cakewalk this is satisfying its
own way of course but it also meant that
I didn't feel pushed to explore the
game's slew of combat adjacent mechanics
nearly as deeply as I would have hoped
things like elemental damage and weapon
modding and consumables jumping into the
supernova difficulty level in a
subsequent playthroughs all that however
combat danger increases your ability to
save your game is restricted and
survival mechanics like hunger and
thirst are introduced making all of the
game's mechanical considerations feel
far more vital the game is more
challenging and interesting because of
it but it's demanding nature definitely
makes them more of a second run option
of course toe-to-toe combat is not the
only solution to your problems the outer
world allows for a variety
avenues for alternative and passive
solutions stealth hacking in speech
related options are available throughout
the game provided you pass the skill
checks the paperwork for killing you
would be the death of me it's nine
possible to complete the game without
getting into at least some combat
unfortunately but to the game's credit
virtually every quest in the game
big or small features branching options
in terms of their paths to success and
how you deal with the big final choices
you have to make the result disputes
which are often deliciously gray when
you hit the end the game runs through a
whole slew of epilogues that describe
how you resolve the game's numerous
major variables and what became of them
and being shown all your exploits up to
some 30 hours makes the whole journey
and your unique path through it really
feel quite meaningful
I finished the outer world wanting more
eager to jump back into the world to see
extra things it's not a short game but
it's one packed with such a steady
stream of wonderful characters to meet
interesting places to explore and
meaningful multi-layered quests the soul
that it didn't feel like there was any
room to get tired of it the outer world
is consistently compelling throughout
and it's a superb example of how to
promote traditional RPG sensibilities in
a sharp modern experience everyone in
calcium is contractually obligated to
label this or another board-certified
jingle their favorite song